the APOD nose knows a lot about Syria
he's a journalist who spent two years as
the hostage of all noose res Syrian
Islamist rebel group and he joins us
tonight
Theo thanks for coming on so one of the
many questions here is who is behind the
chemical attack of the weekend the
chlorine gas attack and and I think we
all assume it is we saw the pictures so
something happened so one of the first
questions is is the Assad regime the
only group in the region that possesses
these weapons of course not we have
videos and I have been in conversation
with these people I mean I live with
them for two years I know what their
goals are in life they are interested in
carrying out an extermination a war of
extermination against their enemies
particularly the Alawite but really
against the Syrian against the Syrian
government and you know they're more
than willing to use any weapon
whatsoever anything it takes to rid
themselves of their enemies I'm quite
persuaded that their their goal is total
annihilation of the enemy and and they
think that chemical weapons will do the
trick and I they talked to me about you
know these ambitions of their is to
exterminate the enemy I have no doubt
that this is you know something that
they desire it's their dream they
believe that they own this land that God
gave it to them and that they should
kick the other people out kill them so
since you spent years as a captive and
are familiar with some of these groups
characterized for us if you will some of
the rebel groups that that the United
States appears to be supporting and that
we hope will take the place of the Assad
regime once they're deposed I mean I can
give you this characterization I can
tell you that the people that we believe
we're supporting I mean as soon as we
give you know a nickel to these people
it goes in ten different directions they
divide every asset that is fungible up
among the people that among themselves
we don't know who were giving our guns
and our money to we just don't and even
though we clear them we vet them and we
train them we don't know what happens
once they go into the country and it's
just it's it's an unexplored emptiness
those places that the rebels control the
reason why we cannot investigate and
figure out who actually committed these
chemical
is because every time you know any
outside person that goes into these
areas is either disappeared or end up in
a cage or tortured or will have his head
cut off so it's really it's quite
impossible to explore the origin of
these crimes it's true that they that
there are a number of possible culprits
but before we go starting any wars we
should investigate properly and we can't
do that now because we cannot access the
scene of the crime
well it rests thank you for reminding us
how complex this all is and you have of
course first-hand experience with it
feel Padnos I appreciate it